the Democratic primary has been
completely shaken up I would argue in
the way that it should be shaken up by
an actual debate and the performance of
candidates within that debate so let me
not praise things I'm not trying to
praise I was hugely critical of the
disastrously lame debate format that the
DNC employed they had two nights of
debate ten candidates per night
60-second responses 30-second rebuttal
'he's not everybody gets to comment on
every issue this is not a format that's
going to really let you learn very much
about anybody's policy in-depth but the
polling has completely changed as a
result of how the candidates did in the
debate and I think that's at least a
good reason for polling to change in the
sense that I don't want polling to
change because if attack ads on TV I
don't want polling to change because of
pac spending I want polling to change
because people are watching the
candidates talk and learning more about
them even if in the debate format that
we have it's more watching their
personalities and their ability to spout
one-liners than it is about the depths
of their policy positions but still
debate and hearing the candidates is the
way that we should be deciding who it is
that we're going to vote for and the
trend lines are super clear so to remind
you my interpretation of how the debates
went was that Kamala Harris and
Elizabeth Warren probably did the best
out of the lead candidates followed by
Budaj edge and Bernie with Joe Biden
doing really poorly and beto or Roark
doing absolutely terribly and then most
of the zeros and ones basically having
no real impact some because they just
don't really have many ideas others
because they didn't have much of a
chance to talk sort of a mixed bag among
two tenors
or more of what we would call the zeros
and ones and indeed every passing day we
are seeing the polling more closely and
more precipitously reflect exactly that
interpretation of how the debates went
putting the graphic up on the screen for
our video audience Joe Biden's polling
has fallen off a cliff
continuing the decline from he had this
pre debate high of about 42 percent down
to the mid 30s then to the low 30s then
to the high 20s and now Joe Biden's
polling average is down to just
26 percent he's still the leader but
this is by a smaller and smaller margin
every single week the big winner since
the debates is Connell Harris I am NOT a
Camille Harris an ardent fan of her
politics particularly her prosecutorial
record in California I'm merely telling
you how she did in the debate from an
optics perspective she did well and now
I am telling you that she has gained a
lot of ground in the polls she is
actually spiked into second place Kamala
Harris in recent polls has surpassed
Bernie Sanders and is now in second
place now averaging just over 15% in the
polls
doubling more than doubling her
pre-debate average of about 7% meanwhile
Bernie has had a bit of a tough couple
of weeks he initially benefited from Joe
Biden's decline but more recently Bernie
has dropped into third place now a
little bit more than a point behind
Kamala Harris important to mention
within the margins of error but
officially in third place right now and
meanwhile Elizabeth Warren's slow but
steady surge continues of about a point
a month she is now up to 13.8% almost
tying Bernie Sanders and I this I like
Warren and I like Bernie I am taking my
opinion about the candidates out of this
and just analyzing the polling data if
the direction if the trajectories
continue the trend line is that
Elizabeth Warren by the end of this week
or by early next week may have passed
Bernie Sanders and may get into third
place okay with Bernie possibly in
fourth place in a week it may not happen
but it may based on the trend lines okay
don't kill the messenger I'm just
telling you what the trend lines suggest
this is going to be a fight okay we have
a truly contested primary here and
what's increasingly clear is that Pete
Budaj edge did not get the energy he
needed from the debate to get past 5%
and become a serious contender bado had
a terrible performance and nothing is
happening with him he's sitting around
2% and meanwhile nobody else has had any
really substantive change I got some
emails from supporters of some of the
minor can
so I got emails from yang supporters who
said Oh David yang is up to two percent
in a post debate poll that's like double
one percent and he was at 1% before well
you were telling me before that he was
really at 2% even though the poll said 1
he's still polling at 0 to 1 in most
polls I like Andrew yang I agree with
him on some policies I disagree with him
on others he's polling 0 to 1 in most
polls that's just the reality ok Ida
nobody benefits from pretending things
are different than what they are
tulsi gabbard supporters saying David
tulsi gabbard was averaging 0.8% before
the debate she's now at one point four
percent she's nearly doubled her support
listen number one you didn't believe the
polls before the debate now you're
citing them as the baseline before the
debate you said there's no way she's
really polling 0.8 now you're saying she
was polling 0.8 and she's doubled it to
1.4 again in the last five polls she's
just polling 1% she's going nowhere okay
so my question to you and this applies
to many of the candidates I have a poll
on my Twitter when should the zeros and
ones drop out and the options include
everything from right now all the way
through never just stay in it until the
very end follow me at D Pakman vote in
that poll and I will have the results
for you a little bit later this week